hello
my name is Caroline I'm a sports
reporter and for the past three years
I've lived in Tokyo
I'm fascinated by Japan a country of
contradictions in vibrant sometimes
through subcultures things are often
completely different than in the West
normally I work behind the cameras for
instance in this piece for DW kick-off
about a futuristic soccer pitch
we're here on the roof of the train
station the location is awesome Shibuya
is full of shops in dat young people
most people don't know you can play
football up here
I also reported for kickoff about fans
watching the 2014 World Cup final at
Tsukiji the world's biggest fish market
Japanese prefer to watch matches at home
so during a big game that's hardly
anyone on the streets it was an
unbelievable experience from East German
to watch my national team win the World
Cup
Monday morning between tuna and mackerel
recently I returned to Germany the
German capital to be precise Berlin it
was hard to get readjusted to my former
hometown I needed to go somewhere
familiar Olympic Stadium I quickly
realized the atmosphere hadn't changed
and the same collection of characters is
still hanging out there
Berlin's Herto made headlines in the far
east when they signed Genki Haraguchi
this season he's the youngest of 13
Japanese players in the Bundesliga and
then it happened I was there to witness
the biggest moment of Kinky's young
Bundesliga career it's in the net
against Shaka
what a moment I imagine it must be
difficult to have sporting success in a
foreign and unfamiliar country I want to
know how the young Japanese forward is
getting on in Germany so I grabbed him
one day after practice on planet pattern
my name is Genki Haraguchi can i play
for her to Berlin I've been here since
July 2014 almost a year his first year
at Herto hasn't been easy his first
coach got fired and now the team is
battling relegation under the new man in
charge paladar died how is it to face
sporting challenges while having to get
used to new city it's nice living in
Berlin there's nothing that puts me off
Germans and Japanese are pretty similar
everything is orderly people are
punctual and stick to agreements nothing
runs according to people's wind power
gucci is the big name in japan he began
his career with the Arava red diamonds a
team that said german coach is like
Keita booth white or like here from the
back Foca finca they usually topped the
table and their fans are passionate her
Iguchi had a heavy heart when he left
and his farewell in Saitama stadium left
me misty-eyed
we've wept together in sadness and in
joy you stood behind me no matter what
so did my teammates my coaches the
officials my friends and family and of
course my girlfriend
of course the j-league is great but in
Japan they place more emphasis on
organized systematic team play here the
players are a lot freer and the
one-on-ones are a lot harder 3303 not
the Kansai that's why I need to improve
in the beginning I realized I wasn't
strong enough so I started doing
additional workouts I think that
nowadays I'm a lot stronger than I used
to be
come here you don't have the strict
hierarchical differences between young
and old that you have in Japan it's
normal for players to joke around and
embrace one another everyone's equal
within the team personally I think
that's great talking to her Iguchi is
like being back in Japan for a bit we
locate a cherry tree and immerse
ourselves in the world of calligraphy by
the way Genki means both how are you and
energy vitality lifeforce courage path
and so on you get the picture
this came out okay
as for me I have learned how much
football makes me feel at home whether
in Berlin or in Tokyo I'm sure that
thanks to young football ambassadors
like Yankee Japan will be paying more
attention to all the stars in the
Bundesliga galaxy
go say ciao arigato gozaimasu they were
matinee
you